[Music]
top ten videos my favorite content on
all of YouTube where else could I
possibly know what the top ten secret
you to tell it's our where else could I
know what the top five youtubers who
destroyed their play but how else can I
find the top five youtubers who caught
ghosts in their videos videos counting
down the top five richest youtubers hey
everybody
and then Tim can talk about the top five
youtubers that didn't suck dick for
views hey everybody today we're gonna
talk about the top ten you to press that
don't like cheeseburgers how's it going
everyone today we're gonna talk about
the top 10 male youtubers that look hot
in bikinis today we got to talk about
the top 10 youtuber haircuts and it's
all clickbait as well you know fair
enough
[Music]
I'm a clickbait a little bit but it's
like top 10 most expensive YouTube
supercars and then there's me and the
[ __ ] thing and it's like implying
that that's my car when I don't when I
Drive a [ __ ] shitty Mini I need to buy
a new car I know but like I I genuinely
have not much interesting cars and
you're using my [ __ ] name and
likeness for this [ __ ] alright today
we're gonna review some of my top top
top 10 shittiest top 10 lists buddy mall
me though there are trust me there's
there's way worse and now I want to
point out there they've all been kind of
nice to me so I don't want to [ __ ]
completely on them you know that
wouldn't I wouldn't be fair to me to
[ __ ] back yo what's going on guys this
is mr. Table five and today in this
video top five youtubers that don't
listen to country music starting at
number one zoella that [ __ ] doesn't
listen to country music six you too but
that doesn't might want to stick my
finger up my hair so starting with your
boy mr. depth I don't like it I love
this of course of course there's one of
people who died oh it's not just who
died it's in 2016 top five youtubers
that died that's the top five top five
right there wait how many died come on
I'll [ __ ] it can't make a top ten out of
that through nine this really really
really did you have to make that out of
people who died did you have to take the
fact that people passed away and make
your [ __ ] top ten list out of it
[ __ ] you
[Music]
I like you know nothing says tragedy
than a giant [ __ ] annotation that
says click this button to subscribe it's
free
what is it 2012 what the [ __ ] so what is
up guys my name is top extracts and
today we're doing kind of a sad topic
this video got copyrighted I won't make
any money
oh no oh can you believe it what now you
know that that's the real tragedy here
this [ __ ] happened to me all the time it
happens to youtubers all the time the
fact that he pointed it out in a video
like this it's [ __ ] amazing
I'm doting my own money to the families
you know I cook off just [ __ ] off you
didn't have to make this video so you're
telling me that you're reaching out to
five different families to donate money
to somehow justify the fact that you
made a top 5 video out of their death
let me just let me just guess how this
conversation went hey it's your boy
pimply faced 69 from YouTube you know no
you don't know me okay well that's you
don't [ __ ] know me so I am making a
top 5 list of people that died on
YouTube and I got great news for you
your your son made the list yeah yeah
it's amazing yeah you want to call it
you want to call your husband and tell
him to oh that's fine oh oh wait yeah
yeah he made it he made the top 5 deaths
yeah I know it's a big big honor
I know oh yeah big big news so anyway I
will be you know I didn't make any money
of the video
yeah I know copyright yeah I can't use
other people's footage yeah it's almost
like some other family copyrighted the
content and took the money no no no I'll
donate anyway because I didn't know I'm
a saint I'm donating anyway so so it
just send me your PayPal account
Western Union I'll be donating you're
taking care of so what is that guys my
name is top extracts and today we're
doing kind of a sad topic I didn't guess
that based on the sad music the sad
piano really sold it for me Oh today
we're doing kind of a sad topic so now
you might be asking why I'm doing this
video yes I am and I would love your
answer it's for a couple of reasons a
couple of reasons great let's hear them
so reason number one Adsense there are
actually some really smaller youtubers
that you guys have definitely not heard
about that have unfortunately passed
away during 2016 so this video is for
those guys and to give back to those
families because of all the revenue I'm
getting from this video I'm gonna donate
it straight to those families that were
affected just don't make the video just
don't make the video if you want to make
a positive cause for these families that
lost someone tragically there are better
ways to go about it then fi you know I
can't tell you why maybe like a GoFundMe
or some [ __ ] but a top 5 video that
doesn't go top 5 on my top 5 best way to
go about it
someone tragic tragically dying in 2016
alright and I just want to help out
pretty much because out of every sad
situation something nice should happen
and I think this should be our way of
giving back to those people at least I
know when I die I'm gonna make it to the
top five youtubers who bad list and I
can't wait for for for this guy to
contact my family and just say hey I got
you it's so [ __ ] stupid the fact that
this video doesn't have more dislikes to
me it's [ __ ] beyond me
there's also top 10 youtubers who were
murdered hey guys what's up it's Charlie
here on a new microphone and today we're
gonna be it's gonna be back about
yes I've been waiting for him Oh finally
it must have been that other top 10
murdered list that you really got it
looking at 10 you tubers who were
murdered we're gonna be looking at
people who were killed because of the
YouTube videos and some other youtubers
who were killed for other reasons this
list is pretty sad but I'm gonna try and
present it in the most sensitive way
possible I can tell by the tone of your
[ __ ] voice hey guys this video is
pretty sad please some videos from some
of the channels but a lot of them have
been deleted please drop a like if you
enjoy listening for two thousand likes
on this video how can you make it top 10
list and start it off with I got a new
microphone and remember to hit like
alright now let's get into number 10
keith ratliff and how do you rank people
step think about that concept for a
second you're basically saying well
keith ratliff died but it wasn't as
important as you know christina grimmie
do you guys think I'd be on a number one
on the top 10 yeah I think it would be
tragic maybe I go in a real tragic way
so I get number one schoiar jeez I sure
hope I get number one this is this whole
thing just bums me out
10 everyday things you need to stop
doing you're a [ __ ] channel how about
we start with that and I know you might
justify these videos as in the sense
like oh well there's no ads on it
so I'm not making any ad sense and
people saying oh I'm
I have ads on it but I'm gonna donate it
to the family's Adsense doesn't stop
it's something that you keep collecting
depending more views are you telling me
that you're constantly donating money to
these families based on you know every
month you get more ad revenue from the
video I sincerely doubt it and if you
were saying that okay well you know what
uh even if you're justifying it in a way
that's like okay well I don't have ads
on the video so I'm not gaining anything
personally from it yeah you [ __ ] do
if you get 16 million users in your
video people are gonna click on more of
your videos or subscribe to your channel
because they found your content
this is so incredibly dumb anyway guys
this video doesn't have any ads on it so
I'm not benefiting from criticizing
these top ten list videos that are not
benefiting from anything and if you see
ads on the video that's a glitch that's
definitely a glitch and you know if you
put a pie out combat this is pretty
newsworthy